the newtonian world is all about the
predictable it's all about predicting
the future but the quantum model of
reality is is about causing an effect
the moment you start feeling abundant
and worthy you are generating wealth the
moment you're empowered and feel it
you're beginning to step towards your
success the moment you start feeling
whole
your healing begins and when you love
yourself and you love all of life you'll
create an equal and now you're causing
an effect
and i think that's the the difference
between living as a victim
in your world saying i am this way
because of this person or that thing or
this experience they made me think and
feel this way
when you switch that around you become a
creator of your world and you start
saying my thinking and my feeling is
changing an outcome in my life and now
that's a whole different game and we
start believing more that we're creators
of reality how do we then go from that
like mechanistically
to begin this visualization process of
something that's empowering it's me in a
different state it's my future self is
it meditation is it
what does that look like if you're not
being defined by a vision of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
network in your brain
every experience that you have with
every person produces an emotion so some
people will use their boss to reaffirm
their addiction to judgment they'll use
their enemy to reaffirm their addiction
to hatred they'll use their friends to
reaffirm their addiction to suffering so
now they need the outer world to feel
something
so
to change then
is to be greater than your environment
to be greater than the conditions in
your world and the environment is that
seductive
so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's close our eyes
let's disconnect
from your outer environment so if you're
seeing less things there's less
stimulation going to your brain if
you're playing soft music or you have
ear plugs in less sensory information
coming to your brain so you're
disconnecting from your environment if
you can sit your body down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here i'm going to feed you when
we're done you can get up and check your
emails you can do all your texts but
right now you're going to sit there and
obey me
so then
when you do that properly and you're not
eating anything or smelling anything or
tasting anything you're not up
experiencing and feeling anything
you would have to agree with me that
you're being defined by a thought right
so when the body wants to go back to its
emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy
you're siphoning your energy out of the
present moment into the past and you
become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's eight o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling angered and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions and you settle it back
down into the present moment you're
telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will
is getting greater than the program and
if you keep doing this over and over
again over and over again over and over
again just like training a stallion
or a dog it's just gonna say
i'm gonna sit and the moment that
happens when the body's no longer the
mind when it finally surrenders
there's a liberation of energy
we go from particle to wave from matter
to energy and we free ourselves from the
chains of those emotions that keep us in
the in the familiar past and we've seen
this
thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
the hardest part about programming
that people don't recognize is you have
to make all programs present tense
positive statements
not future statements i will have i
shall have you know something like that
say no i am it is
and the reason is it's so logically
simple and that is this
uh let's say i'm not well i say i want
to be well and i say fine let's record
that oh now let's come back a whole year
later and push the button and says i
want to be well i said oh it's been a
whole year
you never got there you just wanted to
be well for a whole year that's what the
program said so if you are sick
and you write i am healthy
and the mind looks at the program says
oh i got to change this it doesn't
change the program it brings health back
so that the body matches the program
and so
that that's the whole issue about it the
function of the mind is to take the
program and manifest it and if you've
got a negative program then obviously
whatever manifests is going to be
negative
when we stop expecting things to be the
way that we think they should be
when we stop forcing outcomes and when
we start allowing what is of the highest
good to be our only agenda our only
intention
that's when the universe truly has our
back that's when we can
live what it means to surrender true
surrender comes when we stop
praying for what we think we need and we
start
connecting and grounding in what could
possibly be of the highest
good for all
and when we stop praying for what we
think we need and we start allowing what
is of the highest good for all so true
manifesting is about receiving what is
of the highest good for all and it
begins not just with what well how will
i get what is of the highest good but
how can i be open to what is of the
highest good how can i open up my
consciousness to release what i think i
need and get grounded in what is
possible and what is of the highest good
not just for me and my agenda but the
highest good for all that's the message
so you're doing everything right in that
you're
open to a spiritual practice you're
willing to grow you're showing up for
your practice you're reading books
you're doing the work you're here on
dear gabby you're showing up you're
showing up you're showing up you're
doing a lot of doing though and you're
also doing a lot of expecting and so a
lot of doing and a lot of expecting are
two major blocks to your ability to
attract what it is that you want into
your life and so it's the doing doing
doing that actually creates sort of a
manic manifesting vibration which is how
do i get that how do what am i what do i
do next got to do this thing next got to
do this thing next and that lacks the
belief system that i can be still and i
can allow
that's number one
number two being in the expectation of
what you think things should be is
another block to your manifesting power
and your super attractor power which is
what i call it because your expectations
are limiting the possibilities your
expectations are limiting the highest
good as this card says so when we start
to pray for what is of the highest good
rather than intend and pray for what we
think we need that's when the universe
can conspire with what it is that is of
the highest good for all
so ultimately what's happening is all
the doing doing doing is energetically
blocking
and all the expecting expecting
expecting is blocking the manifestation
as well because when you're in this
tunnel vision of expectation it should
be this way i should be further along i
shouldn't be here what's happening is
you're missing the opportunity to
recognize where you are how great things
are in this moment what is possible in
this moment the creative possibility in
this moment the exciting potential in
this moment you're blocking it blocking
it blocking it blocking it blocking it
blocking it
i want you to sit on your ass
i want you to stop doing doing doing
i want you to
start being
being
being which is what you also said you're
actually dear gabbying yourself
you said i want to embody the feeling i
want to embody the emotion
the being
is a presence it's an energy it's a
state
it's not an action
true manifesting does require
us to show up for our desires you've got
to pick up the phone and then call the
job interview and you have to ask for
the date and you have to to do whatever
it is that you want to create but
ultimately
the greatest source of power that we
have to attract what we want is how we
feel tell us about this belief
where does this block of a belief come
from
and how has it created such a strong
hold on each and every single one of us
well the belief is that we are separate
and that we are individual
and that all
that we consist of all that makes us up
is just a body and a mind and i think
the majority of people would consider
that they're a body and a mind
and the name that they've been given
and the story
uh of their life and i was born here and
parents did this and i do this for a
living and siblings and the story that
we then we identify with and carry
around with us and and
and those stories their story doesn't
matter what the story is it doesn't
matter how fabulous your life has been
it does not compare to who we really are
and so we have this belief that we are
limited
basically in a nutshell that we're a
limited individual that we're born and
that we die
and and that's kind of it and the truth
is we're we are so much more than that
we are certainly having the experience
of being an individual and we're
certainly having the experience having a
human experience but ultimately it is
not who we are and we were never born
and we never die
and
we are
if i were to sum up everything that we
are it's almost the opposite to
everything we strive to be
so we are all the intelligence that
there is we are all the beauty that
there is where all the happiness that
there is we are pure love without any
judgment whatsoever
um
we are complete and utter freedom
which is why freedom means so much to us
why we will fight and struggle to be
free
uh and so we and and we have total
knowing of absolutely everything in the
moment of knowing it we are infinite and
we are eternal
and that is what is actually
experiencing
this
particular form and so we have a belief
that we are an individual that we're
separate that we're born and that we die
and
our mind reaffirms that over and over
and over again through all of its
thoughts and with everything we say with
every thought and every single thing
that we say and actually doesn't the
world affirm that over and over that was
that we're separate
um
but
we are unlimited
we are absolute perfection and and i'm
not talking about the name or the ego
i'm not talking about that because we we
all can see what egos can get up to you
know they can get
they can cause a lot of trouble
egos why eagles want approval they want
attention they want to be right all the
time they judge all of the time and so
you know they're not they're not
something to to attach ourselves to and
to identify with when we are this
incredible being that is lists full
happiness
and so
um
and so we can have a life
where we are living as an individual
human having an individual human
experience
but from the perspective of the infinite
being that we are
in which case we will never be touched
by negativity no matter what happens and
we will remain in lasting happiness no
matter what when we're talking about
energy there's the great law of
attraction of vibration
when things are on the same frequency
there are in resonance all right so
let's not think of the law of attraction
okay
as this thing that's like a magnet that
attracts because
if you were to take magnets and put
together you know positive and positive
it actually will repel it's positive and
negative that are in resonance and
attract
so when we're thinking about the law of
attraction i want you to skip the old
metaphysical laws that you may have
heard of or explanations you heard of
and i want you to think about
resonance so for example if you ever
walked into a room
and not a word has been said and you
know something's wrong and you say
because you're feeling
the vibration you're feeling this
something is wrong your intuition is
picking up the vibration in the room and
you know something's wrong and you go
hey what's wrong and the people in the
room go oh nothing
and you go no no seriously what's wrong
well how do you know that something is
off
and the answer is because this thing
called our body and this thing called
our brain
is and is energy vibrating at a certain
frequency and so when things are not
great we're emitting this frequency that
other
humans can feel we're picking it up with
our intuitive sensors in our brain
and through our field so when we think
about the law of attraction
we should actually be thinking about
am i in resonance right okay
energy that is on the same frequency
will resonate and attract so if you want
to understand the law of attraction
around wealth a relationship health
money are you in resonance
with that which is already here see if
you're thinking positive
but you're feeling negative if you're
thinking uh you know i want to double
triple quintuple my income but inside of
you you're thinking that you're not
smart enough not good enough not not
worthy enough then part of you is
vibrating at the here's what i want to
have be attract etc but if there's
another part of you vibrating at a
different frequency there is no harmony
there is no resonance there's chaos the
thoughts we think and the words we speak
are constantly shaping our world and our
experiences
many of us are in an old habit of
negative thinking and do not realize the
damage we have inflicted upon ourselves
however we are never stuck
because we can always change our
thinking
as we learn to consistently choose
positive thoughts the old negative ones
dissolve away
so as you listen to the following power
thoughts
let the affirmations and ideas wash over
your consciousness
your subconscious mind will pick up the
ones that are important to you at the
moment
these concepts are like fertilizing the
soil of your mind
as you absorb them by repetition you are
slowly enriching the very basis of your
garden of life
anything you plant will grow abundantly
i see you vibrant and healthy
surrounded by exquisite beauty
living a life of love and prosperity
filled with joy and laughter
you are on a wonderful pathway of change
and growth
enjoy your trip
[Music]
my healing is already in process
your body knows how to heal itself
get the negative garbage out of the way
then love your body
feed it nourishing foods and beverages
pamper it respect it create an
atmosphere of wellness allow yourself to
heal
the reason why you are not chasing your
big dream is because you are afraid that
it's going to fail you're afraid that
it's not going to work and what people
will say about you and what you will
think about yourself but what's the
alternative it's sitting on your idea
for years never taking your shot because
you're afraid and living the rest of
your life in regret knowing that you had
an opportunity but were too afraid to
take it the way to not have regrets is
to be always taking action to as soon as
you get an idea go do something about it
i had a great podcast with my friend
mark drager a couple weeks ago a month
ago or so where
he was asking me about regret and i used
to always tell this story of
imagine you have a hangnail how much
that hurts and it's all you can think
about when you have a hangnail but if
somebody punches you in the arm you
don't feel the hangnail anymore because
this hurts more right you focus on what
hurts more and suddenly this one doesn't
hurt as much that's how i would use
regret i would always think about
whatever pain that i'm in right now this
thing that i want to do but i'm afraid i
would imagine that this thing is going
to be the best thing of all time that
this video i'm going to make this speech
i'm going to give this clan i'm going to
make is going to be the best of all time
and if i don't do it i'm going to regret
it for the rest of my life for decades
i'm going to regret not taking action
and so
the pain of doing the thing is the hang
nail and the future pain of regret for
decades is the punch to the arm and so
it inflicts so much pain on me that then
i have to go off and do that thing and i
use that for
[Music]
over a decade
over a decade that's the lens through
which i made decisions and saw the world
but for the past two years i haven't
done that at all i haven't talked about
it i haven't
done it for myself because i talk about
the things that i live
and i'm thinking why why don't i do that
anymore why don't i
use future regret to fuel me
and i found this because i'm always
taking action because as soon as i get
an idea i do something and so i don't
judge the idea i don't say why me i
don't ponder on the idea i don't i don't
just default to strategizing and
thinking i don't think why did i come up
with this why am i thinking about this i
just do it you get an idea you go off
and do it and that's been my mindset for
the past year and a half two years and
as a result
the breakthrough was
you don't live with regret
if you're always taking action on the
ideas that you have you don't live with
regret you might regret some of the
things you end up doing but most of the
things that you regret and other things
done as the actions undone
not undone not taken the action is not
taken you don't regret the things that
you did you get the things that you
didn't do that's most people right there
may be a couple things that you regret
that you did but for the most part it's
the things that you are too afraid to do
that you regret for the rest of your
life and so if you're constantly doing
if you're constantly taking action if
you're always jumping then you don't
have regrets
and it's been an interesting way that i
now see the world and hopefully you can
learn from as soon as you get an idea
you go off and you do something you do
that you won't have any regrets think of
this for a moment
do you know that every living soul gets
exactly the same amount of time
exactly the same amount of time
figure it out
you get all there is
a hobo sleeping under a bridge or on a
park bench
that has no material possessions
none
does nothing of any
constructive nature
that person gets exactly the same amount
of time as the most
productive industrialist in the world we
all get exactly the same amount of time
so it's what we do with the time that
makes a difference
i want you to think of the number of
time management programs almost everyone
under the sun has time management
programs
in fact i made one one time spent a lot
of money on it
and then i found out it was a dumb waste
of time and money
do you know why time can't be managed i
was having breakfast with earl
nightingale one morning
and it was downtown chicago
and i was going with him on a speaking
engagement
and it was early in the morning he said
you want to meet for breakfast
whenever el nino said you want to meet
me i was there and i always had some
well-prepared questions and i remember
asking him i said
how did you learn how to master time
management you know we're having
breakfast i can still hear his fork hit
the plate he's what the hell are you
talking about
he's i've never mastered time management
nobody masters time management he said
time can't be managed
because i merely manage activity
and he took a little card out of his
pocket and he said every night before i
go to bed i write down six most
important things i have to do tomorrow
these are goal achieving activities and
when i wake up that's what i start
working on and if i don't get them all
done i'll add them to tomorrow's list
you should have about six
now if i have three that i didn't get
done today that doesn't mean i have nine
for tomorrow like six plus these three
those three become part of the six you
have to do the next day
when you wake up
you give all your conscious attention to
do those things see you cannot manage
time
but you can manage activity
you can manage your activities
make certain that what you're doing
really makes a difference makes certain
that you're spending your time on
activities that are productive that are
taking you in the direction of your goal
i want to talk a little bit about goals
on the line of how do you lose 37 pounds
and write a book i'm just going to kind
of give you that as an example for 24
years of my adult life by choice i
weighed well over 200 pounds i say by
choice because you see i have never
accidentally eaten anything
i mean it's always been deliberate
and when i choose to eat too much today
i have chosen to weigh
too much tomorrow
you can choose to set goals
and realize your potential
or you can choose not to set them now if
you choose not to set them you got to
understand that the consequences are not
going to be good down the road for 24
years i was going to lose that weight as
a matter of fact in 24 years i lost
several thousand pounds of weight how
many of you already know exactly what
i'm talking about but it wasn't until i
wrote it down
put a date on it
listed the obstacles i had to overcome
identified the people the groups
organizations i needed to work with
spelled out a plan of action set that
time limit in there and identified all
of the benefits to me it was only when i
did that that the goal became a reality
and i lost the weight for 10 or 15 years
i was gonna write a book you know
anybody who's gonna do just a whole lot
of things folks i was gonna write a book
but it wasn't until i got busy
writing the book and writing the plans
first before the book ever materialized
now if it sounds like i'm trying to sell
you on heaven goals how many of you are
getting close already how many of you
becoming convinced right quick like that
you need to have those goals there's no
question about it the immortal j.c penny
many many years ago said give me a stock
clerk with a goal
and i'll give you a man
who'll make history but give me a man
without a gold
and i'll give you
a stock clerk
now the interesting thing is golds do
not care who has them let me give you a
classic example of the way they work in
1950 a war-torn devastated japan a
nation which had lost an incredibly high
percentage of its young men their cities
were in ruins they had been bombed out
but in 1950 they got together they
meaning industry and government got
together and set a goal the goal was
we're going to be the number one nation
in the world during the 1950s in the
production of textiles
in
1959 ladies and gentlemen they
accomplished that objective in 1960 they
set another goal we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of steel now when you
understand there's no iron ore in japan
of any significance there's no coal of
any significance there we're going to be
the number one nation in the world in
the production of steel it seemed like
an absurd goal and yet they reached
their objectives they had taken all of
the steps in 1970 the japanese set
another goal they said during the 70s
we'll be the number one nation in the
world in the production of automobiles
they missed it folks
one year it took them until 1980. in
1980 they set another goal and this time
their goal was we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of computers and electronics
yes indeed ladies and gentlemen you
absolutely must have those goals you got
to write them down you got to put a date
on it you got to identify those
obstacles you've got to identify the
people the groups you need to work with
you got to find out what it is you need
to know you got to develop a plan of
action and you got to write it down
what's in it for me
now that's a formula that i have just
given you pure and simple productivity
is very simple it's a measurement to me
i actually am productive 64 hours a day
and the reason that i'm productive 64
hours a day i call it the power of 64 is
that i focus in on having twice as many
productive hours so most people work
eight productive hours i work 16.
i then focus in on the efficiencies of
those hours to turn the 16 hours to
twice as efficient to 32 hours of
production
and then i look at the statistical
success of what i'm doing to double that
to create 64 hours of production
so when people ask me how do you speak
internationally have your own radio show
on cnbc run a business have a family of
four kids happy marriage travel do all
of these things well it's easy because i
have 64 hours a day that i'm doing
things
and it may sound silly but i've actually
changed my life by creating and playing
with time let me give you some examples
of what to do i take everything
everything that i do by the minute hour
day month year
and i look at it and i create systems
may sound a little ocd or lane or
attentive but it actually works so i
took for example i brushed my teeth lost
my teeth and take listerine every
morning
and i took that and i started realizing
that i would days off and forget what
tooth and it took me an average of six
minutes a day
but if i stayed focused in the morning
and that small little thing that i do
every day i can save four minutes
four minutes time seven day was 28
minutes a week
times four weeks in a month was two
hours a month times 12 months was 24
hours that i regained a productivity all
because i stay focused when i brush my
teeth floss my teeth and take a shot of
listerine
other things happen i realize that time
is compressed in the morning
so i'm not sure if you can looking at me
realize it i've spent hours of wasted
time in the closet wondering what to
wear
i sit there in the morning no matter how
late i am like oh
that or i've lost a sock or i can't find
the right belt
and so i learned this little trick that
i had when i was five years old is i lay
out my clothes at night
but the challenge is when i analyzed
that is i didn't want to take away from
the time with my children at night so i
incorporated that with in laying out my
clothes so i took my girls and i let
them lay out my clothes
so they learned colors and sizes
geography where things were bought
finance i did all kinds of type of
things
and now my six-year-old son because i
travel a lot he actually gets excited
when i leave
because he gets to lay out my clothes
and my oldest daughter who's 17 walks by
and tells me oh daddy i miss laying out
your clothes with you
see how this universal energy
has created itself into efficient
effective statistically successful
things in my life that have nothing to
do with business
it's a matter of putting energy and
creating the habits in performance there
is a reason many of the great women and
men of the world the great history
makers the great poets the great
philosophers the great
movement makers rose before the sun
there is a magic in the air at 5 00 am
and that's why the 5am club is so
transformational because it's the time
of greatest quietude and i believe
tranquility is the new luxury on our
planet it is the time of intimate
creativity because you've just been
rested your brain is fresh there's
there's latest
there's there's very recent cutting edge
science coming out now when you sleep
your brain actually has a mechanism to
wash itself when you wake up in the
morning your willpower is strongest when
you wake up in the morning you've got a
full well of mental focus and we know
that focus in our world is even more
valuable than intelligence and i could
go on and on on the benefits i mean you
get up at 5 00 a.m you've got the world
to yourself there's no crowds you can
think you can plan you can care for
yourself in a world where so many people
are so depleted and so the five it the
5am club really is a game-changer and
then it's not just get up at 5am and you
know scratch your stomach or stare up at
the ceiling or look at your phone or
look at especially not i believe you can
play with your phone or change the world
you don't get to do both yeah and so uh
it the 5am club method is based on the
20 20 20 formula i'm happy to get into
it but that is what it is that's the
revolutionizer and and it started from
my experience with working with many
billionaires i i've coached many of the
most successful financiers and
titans of industry for for over two
decades
and one of the things i would run them
through is the way you begin your day
sets up the way you live your day and so
the 20 20 20 formula that the book is
based upon is pretty simple i i go into
great detail in the book but
essentially it's from 5 to 5 20 the
first pocket is move and i'm a fanatic
about neuroscience and
why do you get up and move because
you're going to release serotonin which
is going to make you feel better you're
going to release dopamine which is the
pleasure and inspirational
neurotransmitter you're going to release
norepinephrine which will boost your
focus you'll promote neurogenesis marie
you can actually grow new brain cells
you'll increase your metabolic rate so
the way you begi the way you feel when
you first wake up is not the way you're
going to feel at 5 20.
second pocket of the 20 20 20 formula 20
minutes from 5 20 to 5 40 that's on
reflection so a lot of us are busy but
what's the point of being busy if you're
doing the wrong things
the the billionaires the great creatives
the people of great impact the people
who live beautiful lives are very
intentional they're very deliberate
they're very conscious so for 20 minutes
you write in a journal
you can visualize you can pray you can
meditate you can simply
contemplate how you're going to live
your day what you want to stand for
during the day for example and then the
final pocket of the 20 20 20 formula is
all about grow and that's where you you
just read from a biography or a business
book or a philosophy book or a watch on
marietv well especially watching tv yeah
of course that's the game changer isn't
it and so that's 20 minutes of growing
because i think we're most alive when we
are growing yes and
i believe the leader who learns the most
wins there's a process which has made
more people rich than any other single
process of goals achieving
and it's to take your major goal and
structure it as a question if your goal
is to earn one hundred thousand dollars
a year then you write how can i earn one
hundred thousand dollars in the next 12
months that's an open-ended question not
how can i earn it at my job or doing a
specific thing just an open-ended
question how can i earn the amount of
money and then you discipline yourself
to write 20 answers to the question
and the 20 answers are all the different
things that you could think of to earn a
hundred thousand dollars work a longer
work harder upgrade my skills
get a new job would take a part-time
opportunity
whatever it happens to be write down
everything you could think of but force
yourself to write at least 20 questions
or 20 answers to the question
the 20 question method called
mindstorming forces you to dig deep deep
into your mind
where you will find all your answers and
it may be call a person
read a book uh let me give you an
example uh we had a young fellow
entrepreneur he got 35 years old he
built a successful business he worked
about 10 years to do it and he for two
years wanted to sell his business so he
could take a year off and travel enjoy
his money and so for two years he just
sort of floundered around like a fish on
the dock wanting to sell his business
nobody uh offered to buy it he suggested
it to people people were not interested
and so on and in this exercise that they
put him through his 20th answer and
often it's the 20th answer that is the
breakthrough was
buy a book on how to sell your own
business
and it just went off like a flashbulb in
his mind at the break he got up as a
downtown hotel got up went down to the
street to a major bookstore went and
found he was amazed at the number of
books had been written on how to buy and
sell a business so he bought two or
three books two months later he had
restructured packaged his business sold
it completely satisfactorily and took a
year off
he said but it's just a single idea it
was a breakthrough idea but it was so
simple just get a book on the subject
and you think boy that's pretty obvious
yes but it's the most obvious answers
that we overlook many of us have issues
with productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burnt out all the time or we're
not productive at all because we don't
know where to start
i found personally being in business for
myself for the last 20 years that i have
been a little overly productive i almost
did too much and i was constantly
multitasking and making things happen
and just moving so fast that ultimately
i really burnt out and i started feeling
brain fog i was feeling disoriented i
couldn't focus i was feeling like even
though i for so many years was priding
myself on the fact that i could get so
much done at one time i actually don't
think i was being nearly as productive
as i could have been
so i hit a bottom recently with this
productivity overload and i realized
that i had to change my patterns i had
to change my ways i was then blessed i
said a prayer i said i need some help
with my brain fog and i need some help
with my productivity issue and i that
day got an email from the dr oz show
asking me to come on and do a segment
with this lovely author and doctor dr
mike dao and me and mike had been in
touch many years
for many years just because he hadn't
been an author we were published by the
same publishers and mike had written a
book about brain fog so that day i'm
like thank you universe you're giving me
exactly what i need i go on dr oz with
mike and i'm backstage with him and i'm
like listen i'm feeling so chaotic and
i'm multitasking so much and my i feel
like i've got brain fog and i'm
forgetting things and he looked to me
and says how much are you doing at one
time and i said oh mike i'm doing a
million things at once i have a thousand
tabs up on my screen and he's like these
are big brain no-no's and they're also
productivity no-no's is what he said
because he said that the more i try to
do and the more i try to multi-task the
less i'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that i want to share with
you that has changed everything for me
and his suggestion was to just do five
things a day
to make a list of the five most
important things that i need to do that
day and not do number two until i've
completed number one and then once i
complete number one move on to number
two then on to number three and if i
don't get through all five in one day
i'll just pick up the fifth the next day
or wherever i left off i'll pick up the
next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things added on to that
list and just be really committed to
that five task list
i did it i started to just be very clear
about the five things i was doing in a
day i told my team i made a a list in my
base camp which is where we keep all of
our notes and i made it really clear to
myself these are the only five things
i'm doing throughout the day
as a result of making it super clear and
conscious to myself that i was only
going to do five things i have been more
productive i have created more have been
more intuitive i have been more inspired
and i've been more creative eighty
percent of you who use a vision book or
a vision board say it changed me
i've told you about my vision board i
had it above my bed i wanted to get
married i wanted to go to africa and
here's a picture of my wedding was such
a here's a picture of me in africa
holding a lion that had been raised from
a cub with a family and it lived there
and it was amazing but i made these come
true i had that vision in my mind i held
that vision i'm
getting married i'm going on safari
and you're never given a vision without
an idea of making it real because what
you want wants you
what you are moving towards is moving
towards you have a vision or a dream or
a wish inside you
get it out of you
put it on paper look at it touch it
read it then you are making it real when
you can look at your vision write all
over your vision
write on it change it mix it up it's not
a dream
you're making it real your potential
expands as you move towards it this will
expand your potential
when you move your mind to a new
dimension it never moves back
never right i wish i dream right i am i
do i can i will i always
i always exercise i can
fit exercise into my life i am
a fit person
i always pick healthy food i can find
healthy food wherever i go i'm the kind
of person that makes eating well a
master priority i can i do i am i always
inspire your mind turn it on with
exciting words turn it on the other
thing about this vision book is it makes
you accountable as you look every day at
the pictures of someone doing yoga or
eating fruit you think well
i better stop looking at that and start
doing it every day as you look at
pictures somebody working from home
socializing looking after their body
horse riding
hiking
making salads as you look at it enough
you become inspired
to take action it motivates you it
inspires you it fills up your mind with
what you want
and it fills you up with a desire a
passion
it motivates you conditions you programs
you compels you to go after what you
want
it holds you accountable
and it's so easy
so don't make it perfect manifesting is
acquiring the experience of what it is
that you want to feel and being and
living and believing in that experience
and then allowing that experience to
come into form sometimes we manifest
things far beyond our wildest dreams so
sometimes if we have a vision of
something it happens in a far greater
way so we want to stay open yep so we
can say i want that macbook air but
maybe we get that macbook air that's a
little bit bigger than we thought yeah
or maybe it comes with an extra little
gift yeah but allowing ourselves to be
open this or something more manifesting
is very creative it is the process of
using your power energy and being in
that presence of your high-powered
energy and allowing that energy to
co-create with the energy that's around
you so you're vibrating at a high
frequency i'm vibrating at high
frequency we've done a lot of work we've
cleaned up a lot of our own crap we
believe in ourselves today and that that
energy of believing in ourselves has
attracted us together today and brought
us into this space where we together are
co-creating and teaching if i hadn't
cleaned up my side of the street and if
i didn't believe in myself the way i do
i would never have manifested being on
marietv miracles occur naturally and
when they're not occurring something has
gone wrong
that's interesting it's a good one right
so what happens is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh i
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be
we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our anxiety our our
anger towards the past that future
tripping and projecting all of that
energy gets in the way of allowing all
of the miracles to occur naturally the
first type of manifestation is to get
very very clear you must be clear
because if you are unclear you'll start
to call in some things that are not
really what you want you'll be confused
the other piece is that once you're
clear you can also then get clear about
all the ways that you don't believe i am
a powerful manifesto you have to meet
the vibration you can't be above or
below it it's just what i was talking
about negative energy
positive energy in order to draw the
thing to you that you want to come you
can't want it so much that you fear that
you won't get it you have to want it so
in order for me to be on your vision
board you must have put it there and
then you let it go yes and then you
weren't thinking about it every day
every day every day because you can't it
doesn't come to you that way you have to
do it and you have to put it and you
have to meet that vibration you prepare
yourself to be there and ready caught
and thinking negatively about the world
and about yourself this is so important
what would change inside of you if you
looked around
and you wrote down five things that
you're grateful for about the world now
this for me
is part of the secret to the law of
attraction it's the foundation is
gratitude it's your way of being must be
grateful in order to attract new things
there's so many things in my life that i
should not have attracted
because i didn't have the skills because
i didn't have the tools because i didn't
have the education because i didn't have
the money because i didn't have the
resources
so many things that i shouldn't have
attracted but because i had the
foundation of gratitude
passion joy curiosity those things
started to come to me and they can come
to you as well if you come from that
place of gratitude as your foundation
so you want to think about what are
these things that are important to me in
my life you know it can be simple things
it could be like this cup of coffee that
i have right now it can be that i have a
roof over my head that i've got quality
friends that i'm healthy
you know that i'm walking in nature
today it doesn't have to be
some grandiose thing that's happened to
you to be grateful for i'm so grateful
for these little present moments
with people that i care about to spend
an hour on the beach to go for a walk
with a friend to have a good
conversation with someone and talk about
something that i'm going through for me
that's just as meaningful
the moments in between the big moments
are just as meaningful so write down
these things or think about these things
this is something i embed in my daily
life when i wake up i think about what
i'm grateful for when i go to sleep i i
think about and reflect on the things
i'm grateful for from that day and it's
just my way of being for as much as i
can now i'm not perfect i make mistakes
and there's some times i'm negative
but it's something that i try to really
focus on as much as possible so instead
of saying that you're not enough
that you don't deserve success what if
you looked in the mirror on a daily
basis i dare you to look in the mirror
on a daily basis and say i am enough and
i do deserve
the results that i want to create in my
life because i show up because i'm
consistent because i work hard because i
care about my work if you looked in the
mirror and you did this consistently for
30 days and you actually
use the word action in attraction and
you put it into practice on a daily
basis towards that growth
i'd be amazed to see what you attract
and what you manifest in your life
there's a primary law called the law of
vibration
the law of vibration decrees that
everything in this universe moves
nothing rests
the body in a coffin is moving
probably you're probably thinking this
guy's smoking something like if the body
in a coffin wasn't moving how would it
ever change to dust
it's always moving it's always vibrating
everything vibrates we live in an ocean
of motion take a microscope and look at
a solid wall
it's not solid it only appears to be
solid or perception problem there you'll
see the wall moving right in front of
your eyes there's a particle of energy
and they're dancing right before your
eyes that's a lot of vibration the law
of vibration decrees everything moves
nothing rests we literally live in a
notion of motion now this physical
instrument we're living in we call our
body is a molecular structure and it's
in a very high speed of vibration
our brain is an electronic switching
station
when we activate brain cells we alter
the vibration in different parts of the
body i could not move my hand up and
down or my arm up and down without first
giving a message to my brain to do that
well the brain activates cells in the
body it sets up a vibration in the body
the
vibration that the mind and body are in
is going to dictate what you attract
because when you put yourself in the
vibration what you're really doing is
put yourself on a specific frequency
that's what you do when you set a goal
most people set a goal and then wait for
it to happen and never going to happen
you've got to assume that it's already
happened you've got a picture of it in
your mind mentally it's already happened
it's happened because i've got the idea
in my conscious mind if i didn't have
the idea of my conscious mind i couldn't
talk to you about it the very fact i can
talk to you about it means that i've
already got it
then i've got to get emotionally
involved in it
i'm already emotionally involved in the
goal that i've got i've got it
intellectually i've got it emotionally
it's only a period of time till it moves
into form how does it move into form
well you attract whatever is required
for it to move into form you attract all
the energy that's necessary to produce
the physical result how do you do that
you do that by intellectually
emotionally staying in the vibration
of the good that you desire you see it
already in the present tense so that
keeps you on the frequency
and that frequency then dictates what
you're going to attract you can only
attract to you what's in harmonious
vibration with you
now if you're holding an image that you
can't get something you're on a
vibration you're not going to get it but
if you can see yourself with it you know
it's coming to you you know it you know
it's only a period of time you're not
quite sure what the time is but you know
it's a period of time and bang that
thing's going to manifest in your life
you have controlled the vibration that
you're in the vibration then called the
frequency you put yourself in the
frequency that you good your desires on
let's suppose i want to have a lot of
money we're just talking about money now
this is a lot of money relative to let's
say
this there's one 100 here's 10 100 100.
so one's a lot relative to the other
neither one is a lot it just is
if i want to attract a lot of my i got
to see myself with a lot of money i got
to mentally accept i've already got it i
don't let my bank account dictate that i
choose that
so choosing myself to see myself with
the good i already desire i'm on that
frequency now the trick is to stay on
that frequency
most people look at the results and they
let the results dictate the frequency
they're on that's why they keep getting
the same results
they have the image in their mind
they're already reached the goal they
want they're already successful and
somebody else comes along and say well
you haven't got those results
in my mind i have but they're not
looking in my mind they're looking at my
present results and then pretty soon i
start listening to them i think god
they're right i look at my results i
haven't got it
do you see why we keep getting this poor
results
you've got to see yourself with the good
you desire you've got to hold that image
in your mind you've got to know it's
going to come and that will attract
everything that's necessary see nothing
is created or destroyed everything's
already here if not in one frequency
certainly in another or not in one state
certainly in another we've got to get on
the frequency of the good that we desire
when you notice that you're in that
story and that trauma of your you know
negativity fear or judgment attack
that's making you feel bad notice it
notice the thought right away
and then you say how is this thought
making me feel
step one notice the thought and how is
it making me feel
and the second step is to forgive
yourself for having the thought not
beating yourself up why am i i used to
do this all my life why am i having such
an idiot why am i so stupid why can't i
figure this out what is wrong with you
that was my pattern for years i know i
know
so how do we get out of that forgive
yourself for having the thought forgive
the thought if you can't forgive
yourself for having thought cause that
just feels too heavy for you just
forgive the thought like okay that's
that's that thought again
that's from my childhood trauma that's
from mike's you know my fear of this
that's from whatever there it is again
and then the third step is to start to
proactively choose again and this is
where we begin to reach for the next
best feeling thought we reach for this
is a very influenced by abraham hicks
which is written you know mentioned 23
times in that book what was it called
like the purge of appreciation or
something else
of appreciation yeah so when you want to
choose again in that third step you're
going to reach for a thought that you
believe in so what if you don't believe
in any good thoughts you you have you
have a thought that could be better and
here's here's what it could be it could
be
i
can turn on lewis house's podcast right
now and that might make me feel better
that that's a that's a thought right
right or i have that book that i could
open a page too and maybe it will give
me inspiration or you know just
something as simple as like i'm gonna go
for a walk for five minutes that might
make me feel bad right so and then you
keep going you keep reaching for it so
you reach for
the thought uh i'm gonna go for a walk
i'm gonna let myself feel better then
you go you know you go for that walk and
uh i'm gonna just listen to some music
that music might make me feel better or
the next thought could be i actually
have dinner tonight with my friends so
that will be great and i can bring
myself to that uh but little things like
my credit card got stolen and i'm on the
phone with the credit card company and
i'm i'm trying to get out of the hotel
with my son and
i have a nanny with me so like my
nanny's like uh oh the baby pooped you
know i'm on the phone with the credit
card company there's no uber in santa fe
and the baby's pooped and you're just
like you know these moments and so i
start going into the i'm out of control
so i notice it really quickly now i
witnessed the thought
i forgive myself for acting out and
being rude to the woman at the credit
card company and then i choose again
okay let's change the poopy diaper let's
get in the car
at this moment yes i could have carried
that negative thing all the way down to
santa fe having lunch but i decided to
turn it around quickly yeah and that's
how we can we can start to live like
that so i get a call from my one of my
team members and she's like uh don't go
on facebook i was like what she's like
there's a whole
person's facebook page and they're
railing on you and they're going off
about you
and
maybe like 30 people had chimed in being
like oh you hate gabby mercy thank god
somebody's talking about it
just like you know going after me yeah
and well 30 people is a small number in
the grand scheme of the universe this
feels really overwhelming and and even
one person hating you on the internet
can can shake you to your core
so i
l i just i do what anyone would do in
that moment and i start to go down that
hole of of shame and upset and what did
i do wrong and how could i have
triggered these people in this way and
what you know what is my part and just
getting so hooked into it even though
you know a lot of what was being said
was being said without any information
right uh you know but regardless i
didn't even need to dig into it to feel
the feelings of discomfort and i was
getting really really hung up about it
really hung up about it and took you
know probably it was about a full day of
just like
being down and bummed out and i remember
i was watching television with my
husband at night i was staring at my
phone just being like did more people
weigh in like what's happening and he
looks at me he's like what is going on
what you can't even be present with me
in this room why are you so stuck in
this i was like it feels so horrible to
be
you know pounded on on the internet and
i'm so upset about it and he said listen
you've got it all wrong girl this is
what my husband became a guru he said
you are focusing all your energy on
these 30 people who are hating you but
you have thousands of people on your dm
on instagram that are trying to send you
love that are asking you questions that
want your support and you don't even
know how to find your dm
you and me were in the same boat for a
long time
and he's like you don't even know how to
find it he's like let me show you how to
find your dm and focus on the people
that need you not on these people that
are hating on you so
i spend the next four days just dm'ing
dm i mean dm like i went on my instagram
i was like yo who wants to dm
and so i'm just like in it and in it and
i'm just feeling so like within 48 hours
i was just like so transformed by just
being in the service of others and
connecting to the people that really
wanted to to hear from me and wanted my
support and what happened that was so so
transformational was i woke up one
morning a few days into this and i woke
up at like 5am and i was i was upset by
the still a little upset yeah the
thought came right back in oh there they
are why are they talking about me of
course and in that moment i was like
okay zach said get on dm so i get back
on my dm and i start damning and i see
this girl and she's talking to me and
she's saying you know listen i um was
sober for two years i just went out i
feel like i'm i want to commit suicide
right now i started dming with her
within the hour i'm on the phone with
her
and
that day she made a commitment to go
back to recovery
so i have deep gratitude for those
haters because those haters gave me this
beautiful opportunity of service to
somebody and potentially save her life
and and and and also just get over it
when you
before i i mean this must have been five
years ago that we did an interview and
it was before i really
understood why i was so
in control why i was needing to because
i hadn't remembered my trauma and i had
you know i was living in fight or flight
i was an extreme pusher uh and in that
energy we may be able to create some
successes but we will never have that
that life that is what we truly want
fulfillment inner peace and we block
bigger stuff too we block bigger stuff
we block it because our energy is just
so frenetic
uh there's also the
the person who's like the manic
manifester who is very a lot of my
audience can identify with this they're
like you know reading all the books you
know reading watching lewis house
watching this you know doing this
meditation every single day
and they're just like why am i not
manifesting why am i manifesting but
it's because they've made their
spiritual practice another form of
addiction what is the thing that they
need to let go of the most if they are
doing the habits and they are doing the
steps and they are following your work
you just said it they just need to let
go
it's like you can practice these
principles but not because you think
you're going to get something you have
to practice these principles so that you
feel good and this isn't actually a book
on how to get things though it sounds
like it it's a book on how to feel good
yeah because when we feel good we're
super attractive we attract more yeah
super attractive the first step to
feeling good is to decide to stop
feeling bad i write in the book about
how
i'm going to push the metaphysical
envelope and i'm going to go to places i
haven't gone before and i never went
there before because i didn't want to
alienate my reader and i had a lot of
new seekers that were joining me on this
journey but i feel right now that people
are completely ready for this
conversation and they can take it or
leave it yeah and make it their own yeah
and my beliefs do not have to be theirs
that's a really important point that
whatever we believe when we think about
a higher power spiritual presence is
what we believe and all that matters is
that you believe it not that someone
said it's this or that it's it's it may
be a religious spiritual belief system
it may be a belief system from your
childhood maybe something that you read
in a book that resonated with you you
decide that's the beautiful thing about
being on a spiritual path but what i
share is what i believe to be true about
what it means to connect to the voice of
our higher self our inner guidance
system and our inner wisdom versus what
it means to rely on a guide or a angel
or a deceased family member
or a loved one and so i believe we all
have these two this t we all have a team
of of guides of spiritual guides that
work on our behalf all the time and what
they're there for is often to guide be a
bridge for our thoughts so when our
thoughts are in those low vibrations if
we pray to a guide or we pray to god or
we pray to an angel we can say thank you
for for bridging my thought from this
low vibrational fear-based belief system
to a higher vibe and the way that they
would do that maybe by putting a book in
front of you or guiding you to a episode
of marietv that is going to just change
your mind so guides work through the
internet and books and people and and
and your and your subconscious and so
you're gonna maybe when you have those
moments where you're like i have this
sense that i need to to watch that
episode of marietv right now maybe
somebody watching just got the hit yeah
that could have been your guide just
giving you that boost of inspiration
watch that watch that because that's
going to change you and so don't
underestimate those moments of
synchronicity because there's support
that's leading you in those
synchronistic moments and so the more
that we align with our spiritual belief
systems and the more we
allow ourselves to accept that it's good
to feel good and the more we use things
like the emotional guidance scale or the
choose again method or any of the
methods in this book the better we feel
and the better we feel the more we can
hear the guidance that we're receiving
the guidance is always there but we
block it we cut it off and so we can
open up to that guidance i've been
really working on getting honest and
telling the truth and being forthcoming
about how i'm feeling i know this is
something that can be very squirrely for
people we can get really hung up about
actually saying how you feel and telling
the truth but when we don't tell the
truth we actually stifle our energy we
create toxic relationships we carry
resentments and it builds up and builds
up and builds up so i've gotten into the
practice of just radically telling the
truth wherever i am however i need to be
authentic and truthful about what i'm
feeling but i have a few steps that i
think are important that you need to
take in before you actually give that
truth over because if you share your
truth without cleaning up your side of
the street it'll feel like an attack
it'll feel like judgment so the process
of telling the truth is quite simple
first take a look at your side of the
street look at what's up for you if you
feel called to get honest with somebody
what is it within you that's feeling
triggered what is it that's that's
feeling activated and do whatever you
need to do to clear that whether it be
forgiving yourself for giving the other
person saying prayers for that other
person sending loving energy to that
other person and clean up the energy
before you bring over the truth because
you don't want to show up with this
nasty attitude because your truth won't
be heard you need to bring your truth
with a lot of light so that they can see
their light reflected back to them
so the process is really simple look at
your side of the street before you show
up and tell the truth and then be
prepared to get honest from a place of
love if you can tell the truth from a
place of love then you will be heard and
that's when you feel healed and that's
when a healing can be offered up to the
relationship but as long as you're
telling the truth from a place of
negativity or judgment it will not be
heard and it won't work i learned this
the hard way unfortunately but the
experience has given me this great
opportunity to learn how to tell the
truth with grace and power
the benefit of telling the truth is that
you start to feel like you're taking
care of yourself you start to feel like
you're owning your voice you're owning
your needs you're protecting yourself
when you need to protect yourself and
you're sticking up for what your values
are no matter what and you're also just
you know really getting clear about what
your boundaries may be within certain
relationships and so sometimes people
may not like your truth but you could
always trust that if you're sharing your
truth from a place of love you will be
heard even if they get defensive even if
they get upset that your loving presence
is enough to allow that truth to come
through in a very authentic way
the other part that may be very helpful
is once you've told your truth give the
person their opportunity to tell their
own hold that space for them to say how
they feel there's always two sides to
every story so speak up and then allow
the other person to speak up clearing
that space for the truth to unfold and
trusting that the truth will totally set
you free my mom always always said this
to me for my entire life the truth will
set you free the truth will set you free
and i believe that we all want freedom
we want freedom from resentment freedom
from anxiety freedom from fear and that
freedom is available as we start to open
up to the truth within us i once heard a
definition of health that made a lot of
sense to me
good health it said
is having no fatigue
having a good appetite
going to sleep and awakening easily
having a good memory
having good humor
and having precision in thought and
action
not being klutzy
being honest
humble
grateful and loving
how healthy are you
i do not heal anyone
the work i do is to help people
understand how their own mental patterns
are constantly creating their own life
experiences
all of them
the good experiences
and the so-called bad experiences
and also
how these same mental patterns are
contributing to the ease
and dis-ease
in their bodies
we do not want to be ill
and yet we need every disease we have
it is the body's way of telling us
that we have a false idea in
consciousness
our body is telling us
we are on the wrong track
and need to change the way we think
every illness
is a lesson
for us to learn
please do not just complain i want to
get rid of this condition
it will not create the healing you want
nor will you learn the lesson you need
to learn
this is not a time for condemnation
or for creating more guilt
we are just looking at what needs to be
released
this is a time for healing
for making our lives and our bodies
whole
i know
you have within you all that you need to
accomplish this
once we begin to understand this process
we are able to take conscious control
of the changes we wish to make in our
lives
this is a very exciting process
and becomes one of the most important
adventures in our lives
i believe there is a center of wisdom
within each one of us
and when we are ready to make positive
changes in our lives
we attract whatever we need to help us
something inside of you has shifted
and the healing process has already
begun
you might even say that to yourself now
i have already begun
the healing process
the body like everything else in life
is a mirror of our inner thoughts and
beliefs
the body is always talking to us if we
will only take the time to listen
every cell
responds to every single thought you
think
and every word you speak
continuous modes of thinking and
speaking
produce body behaviors and postures and
eases or diseases
the person who has a permanently
scowling face
did not produce that by having joyous
loving thoughts
older people's faces and bodies
show so clearly a lifetime of inner
dialogue
how will you look when you are elderly
you see it is my belief
that it is our birthright to be totally
healthy and totally fulfilled
in every area of our lives take a nice
deep breath
and if possible
allow yourself to be in a comfortable
position
just let these ideas wash over you
only those ideas that are right for you
will be accepted by you
it doesn't matter whether you understand
them all or not
or if they make sense to you right now
your subconscious mind will hear and
record whatever you need
i believe that all illness is
self-created
not that we say i want to have this
illness
but we create a mental atmosphere where
this dis-ease can grow and flourish
our internal mental dialogue
reacts in every cell
in the body
i heard a physician say recently
if the surgeon operates on a patient
without doing something to help them
change the cause of the disease
then all the doctor is doing is
prolonging the life of the patient
until the patient can create another
dis-ease
you see we need to do more than just
treat the symptom
we need to eliminate the cause of the
dis-ease
and for that we need to go within
ourselves where the process of illness
began
it is my belief that we are each
responsible for every experience in our
lives
the best and the worst we all create our
experiences by the thoughts we think and
the words we speak
the universe totally supports our
internal dialogue
our subconscious mind accepts as truth
whatever we choose to believe
you can say it either way
they both mean that what i believe about
myself and about life becomes true for
me
what you choose to think about yourself
and about life becomes true for you
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want to learn to
become supernatural with dr joe dispenza
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
i'll see you there if you teach people
to broaden their focus
to begin to instead of focusing on
everything material and physical that's
causing the stress everything that's
known
broadened their focus